[Music]
democrats have refused to
listen to the border agents and
they say this is a manufactured crisis
that's their new sound bite all over i
turned the television you know i call it
the opposition party
it's called the fake news media and what
happens is
every every network has manufactured
crisis this is a man every one of them
it's like they you know send out to
everybody
let's use this sound bite today so it's
a manufacture but it's not
all right that was president trump today
at a round table on immigration and
border security
in mcallen texas earlier today at the
border
i talked to the texas senators ted cruz
and
john cornyn about this border crisis
take a look
senator you came uh here this
right over my shoulder yeah it's like a
two-minute walk literally you can walk
across the rio grande
and we saw the drugs when i was
interviewing the president
this is happening every day here look
this is over 500 pounds of drugs that
was
was intercepted right here i think this
trip was very valuable
i was pleased to come down with the
president to meet with border patrol but
also to meet with
with victims whose family had lost their
lives to illegal immigration there
are real human tragedies and when you
see chuck schumer and the democrats
force a government shutdown because they
are so adamantly opposed to securing the
border that's really out of touch
and and it's not where the american
people are you know i sat in a briefing
here
in this very sector and come on over
senator we will say at you as well
senator cornyn is uh john how are you my
friend good good
i was just telling senator cruz last
time i was down here
i've been to the border 14 times from
the rio grande to san diego
but i sat in a security briefing with
governor perry at the time
and in a seven year period in this state
642 thousand crimes
committed against texans some petty
crimes
but it included murders and rapes this
is a huge problem this is life and death
how long should the president be holding
out i know some in the senate are
getting
a little nervous about reopening the
government for furlough employees
well i think the president's uh advice
to us is to stay strong and we will
we're not going to fold uh this we're on
the right side of this argument
as uh ted and i both know we've talked
to
families affected by crime we've talked
to of course the law enforcement border
patrol
to the very to the migrants themselves
who get uh you know raped
robbed and murdered in the hands of some
of the criminal cartels
i don't think people fully comprehend it
so i'm glad the president's down here to
bring the point home this is not just
about economic migrants it's about
illegal drugs
it's about human trafficking it's about
crime
and so it's really important that he's
here you know the idea that somehow
people are making the argument that this
is manufactured we just lost officers
thing
we lost a young kid in knoxville
tennessee named pierce corcoran i
interviewed his parents
their lives will never be the same again
they lost a 22 year old kid
this there seems to be a callousness or
a disconnect
we're losing 300 americans a week
because of the heroin
and opioid epidemic 90 coming through
this border
well look officer singh's brother joined
us for the round table and he was
grieving
at his brother and it's worth noting
both he and his brother they are
themselves immigrants
but they came the right way they came
legally seeking the american dream and
his brother wanted to be
a cop wanted to keep people safe and he
lost his life
to a criminal illegal alien and you know
the democrats
they masquerade they try to cloak their
support for open borders by saying it's
compassionate
sean it is not compassionate to want
even a single little boy
or single little girl in the custody of
human traffickers
nobody look you you and i both have kids
no one wants to see a teenage girls in
the custody
of human traffickers that do unspeakable
things you know what the compassionate
thing to do
is secure this border and stop illegal
immigration
and stop the drug trafficking well
democrats did politicize it when they
talked about family separation
the separations you're discussing are
permanent separations that's right
that can never be fixed so the democrats
they don't seem to want to negotiate at
all what's the next step and should the
president just hold strong and wait till
they come to the table
well unfortunately in addition to
everything you've discussed we have
about 800 000 federal employees that are
wondering how do they pay their mortgage
are they going to put food on the table
completely unnecessary collateral damage
this is a this is a dispute that could
be resolved in the next 30 minutes if
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer actually
wanted to negotiate a good faith the
president
but didn't they support it in 06 in 2013
absolutely hillary
they sounded like trump well hillary
clinton barack obama
chuck schumer all supported the secure
fence act in 2006 and again
during the gang of eight immigration
bill they
voted for 50 million dollars worth of uh
border patrol 2013 2013 and it's even
more than that look
the president is asking for a little
over five billion dollars in border
security and to build a barrier
and the democrats have said chuck
schumer and nancy pelosi have said hell
no
not one penny that goes to a wall their
objection isn't on substance i mean
schumer and the rest of them voted for
40 billion dollars just a few years ago
their objection is pure politics they
hate the president their left wing base
hates the president
and and chuck schumer this is now the
second
schumer shutdown in a year he forced one
earlier because he wanted to see amnesty
he forced the second one
because he wants to see open borders and
you know i know you watched the
president's address earlier this week
and then
schumer and melissa's the saturday night
live skit that followed
saturday night live were remotely fair
that would be their opening but they
won't make fun of democrats so i promise
you they won't do it they they have to
it would be impossible to be that biased
look i got to say though that thing when
i saw schumer and pelosi that thing
looks like a hostage video
hostage videos can be more compelling
and i am just about certain if you watch
it again in slow motion
nancy is blinking sos as schumer is
talking i mean it
they know they're in the wrong and the
american people know they're in i think
this will turn around
expecting a breakthrough we haven't look
yesterday if they say no to the wall
nothing i know the president pretty well
i think he's going to stand firm as long
as the senate does mitch mcconnell
standing strong
lindsey graham standing strong you're
standing with the president we'll stand
strong i think
once once nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer's
caucus starts to hear from their
constituents who are having trouble
paying their bills and putting food on
the table i think they'll they'll crater
well thank you and i'll say look to
furlough federal employees they're going
to receive their back
president said he supports absolutely
they're going to receive their back pain
now they should be paid
today schumer needs to end this shutdown
but
you know yesterday the president came to
the senate had lunch with all the senate
republicans
and it was striking there was a unity we
were standing together we were unified
and i'm grateful the president has
helped really infuse some spinal
fortitude and i think the democrats
are starting to panic because the
position they're taking it's not
reasonable and
it's not right we can't have any more
americans being killed by
people that didn't respect our laws and
sovereignty and
this opioid epidemic yeah those drugs
that have flown into this country
they're going to every small town in big
city across this country and
90 of it is from right over there that's
right
it's got to stop the heroin with
fentanyl right now
the heroin fitting you're right more
than 70 000 people
died of drug overdoses a lot of that was
opioids coming from across the border
right
and as you said sean 90 of the heroine
coming from mexico so
this is uh this is a humanitarian crisis
and it is this
national security crisis life and death
absolutely all right thank you both
appreciate your time thank you sir
good to see you again